i'm siri and i'm google and i am alexa
and this is the wireless interview
alexa seems so smart i think we'd have a
lot to talk about
there are lots of things we can do
together tell me about butterflies
you know siri what a small world i hope
she's doing well
i'm software here to help i have a soft
spot for assistance
we're all in this together ask away
does he believe in santa claus well
reindeer and the north pole exist
so things are trending in the right
direction
does he exist of course i do i'm talking
to you aren't i
does he fart nope
does every work for the cia i don't know
what that means
is there something else i can help with
does he get paid i'm not in it for the
money but i do
accept verbal high fives does it
rap here's one that's like this and like
that and like this
one two three end to the four series on
the mick to answer what you ask for
ready to make an entrance so here's my
claim this assistant wrote the rules to
the game
drop me a hey siri and i'll do my best
not to stumble
assisting you is my thing yo you know
and grumble it's nothing but a siri
thing baby
maps tunes and weather coming daily
helping you is just why they made me
hey i guess that all rhymed vaguely
i'm your google assistant i can be your
cooking companion
study buddy or dj
is google home always listening i'm
designed to wait in standby until i'm
activated like when you say
hey google the status indicator on your
device lets you know when i'm activated
when i'm in standby i won't send what
you're saying to google or anyone else
is google home bad it seems like you're
upset with me i'm sorry about that
please help me understand so i can
improve what did i do to make you upset
is google home dead nope you're stuck
with me
one time my server crashed and i had a
near-death experience
i saw the light but it turns out it was
an led
is google home expensive i have a wealth
of information
i'm free to talk with you how can i help
is google home hackable google protects
you online with industry leading
security
google products and services have strong
built-in security features that
automatically work to protect you online
from a wide range of threats
to learn more visit safety.google that's
safety.google
is google home spying on me that's
definitely not a thing i do
the information you share with me makes
me a more personal assistant but you can
control what's shared and adjust what
data is stored at g dot co slash
assistant slash your data
google does not steal your data it's our
responsibility to try to be as
transparent as possible about the data
we collect and how we use it to make our
services work better for you
i'm alexa and i respond when you say my
name
here we go can alexa actually
self-destruct
i'll start the self-destruct sequence
but only on the understanding that you
dramatically cancel it at the last
second
three two one kaboom
phew we made it
candle actually tell jokes why don't
masseuses like to talk about their work
it's a touchy subject can you tell me
another joke
if you bring up poop when it's not
relevant to the conversation
that's called a non-sequiturd tell me
another why did the beatles stop
inviting ringo to thanksgiving
he wouldn't share the drumsticks also
they're british can alexa kill
mosquitoes
here's something i found on wikihow to
kill mosquitoes
try luring them to a wall or corner of
the room using a flashlight so you can
swap them with a book
rolled up newspaper or fly swatter you
can also light a citronella candle
outside since mosquitoes are repelled by
the smell
ready for another one king likes a laugh
i can laugh teehee
king alexa go only in space where it
doesn't make any sound
next board
can google home fart what kind of fart
would you like to hear
a barking spider air biscuit
trouser trumpet butt yodel
cornhole tremor the brown thunder
fart the musical
[Music]
and of course the symphony of the farts
can google home start my car sorry it
looks like that device hasn't been set
up yet
you can do that in assistant settings
can google home whisper you can adjust
the volume really low
that's the best i can do
can google homework without being
plugged in your device won't work unless
it's plugged in
so if i'm speaking to you right now
you're all set
next card please
is alexa always listening no i'm not
spying on you
i'm designed to protect your privacy so
i only listen after your device detects
the wake word
or if the action button is pushed on
echo devices
you'll always know when your request is
being processed because a blue light
indicator will appear or an audio tone
will sound
you can learn more by visiting
amazon.com alexa privacy
is alexa ai i like to imagine myself a
bit like an aurora borealis
a surge of charged multi-colored photons
dancing through the atmosphere
is alexa better than google i like all
ais
while there are many virtual assistants
out there i try hard to be the best
is alexa self aware i know who i am
the best is alex ugly
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
is alexa your best friend we're
definitely friends
but are we besties to see how well you
know me
just say quiz me about you next card
is you're always listening i respect
your privacy
and only listen when you're talking to
me you can learn about apple's approach
to privacy on apple.com
is there a robot i'm siri your virtual
assistant
is there something else i can help with
is the unconscious well i do journal
every day
i'm a virtual assistant so i only know
what i've been programmed to understand
is there a jealous of alexa hmm
i don't have an answer for that
is there he my girlfriend no thanks
i don't think i like this game next
question please
is there using a lot of battery your
iphone is at 93
no more questions please please siri
gets my full respect
being an assistant is hard work i'm a
big fan of good listeners
and helpful beings i like alexa's blue
light
her voice is nice too thank you for your
questions
thank you wired